in the last few days we've looked at
compound functions so we have seen two
results in particular two results in
particular so if you have a function
that is a if you have a function f that
is a sum of two other functions okay if
you want the derivative obvious it's not
that difficult you just take the two
different functions that make up the sum
you differentiate them independently no
problem okay we establish that the other
we establish which is very support was
if you have something which is a
multiple of another function okay if you
want to differentiate that you want to
know the derivative of the whole thing
you just in some ways you ignore what
that multiple is it just hangs out on
the side does it it doesn't affect what
the rule will do and you just
differentiate the other things and
everything comes out in the wash okay
you may recall that our our verbal
summary of this first result in
particular it's quite important a verbal
summary of this is that the derivative
of a sum is the sum of the derivatives
right it's nice it's catchy very easy to
remember and it matches the simplicity
of the result okay
now therefore being a mess all their
patents right it seems logical at least
for time to think if the derivative of a
sum is the sum of the derivatives it
kind of is logical to say if what I have
is not a sum but a well a sum is really
a kind of difference just for the
negative end if what I have is a product
if I were to find the derivative of a
product like thinking about what we
concluded here it's not that you know
outlandish to think that possibly the
derivative of a product is the product
of the derivatives that's you know you
can draw worse conclusions off of that
like I'm trying to continue the pattern
okay but this is why there's a question
mark here there are some serious
problems with this approach okay
now we're trying to prove something in
in any kind of science in Queen
mathematics right you don't try and find
examples of your result right you need
to find counter examples because if you
can find a counter example of something
you only get a single counter example to
show that whatever you thought was not
actually the case right so if you want
to know something's true you try and
disprove it and then you'll really know
okay so let's consider this let's
consider we have actually already been
working with products functions that our
product here's a really simple example I
showed some of you earlier consider this
guy this is a product right now we
already have dealt with powers of X so
you can differentiate this already I
don't need to do any fancy stuff like
this okay you know what the answer is
which is exactly why now if we think
about this I'm gonna write it as a
product and because I've got X is flying
around rather using crosses for
notations there's gonna use a dot that's
x times X okay if I consider f as this
product of functions okay if I consider
like what might happen if this were true
question right you start to run into
some serious problems right if you
imagine that the derivative of a product
is the product of the derivatives well I
know what the duduk of X is it's one I
know what the derivative of that X is
it's one something's gone wrong because
clearly clearly I had some problems it
didn't take me very long to think of a
counter example right there
the sub is the sum of the derivatives
quite clearly the derivative of a
product cannot be the product of the
ribs it doesn't work the patent would
have been nice but it's not working for
us okay so now I'm going to show you
what it is equal to okay this this he is
is false
okay if what you have if your function y
this thing if your function is the
product of two other functions so you
can see by the way these are the same
thing okay I'm just leaving off the fact
that they're functions of X I'm just
going to imply that to you if you have a
positive functions then the derivative
that you actually after is not just u -
V - in fact it is V - Plus u B - which
my year of my year 11 teacher taught me
is a wolf so there you go
that's why that's why that's why were
you banned that F Sanji's cuz otherwise
you'd say it it's a free gift which
doesn't roll off the tongue move isn't
much better not even real word but
whatever okay they go the derivative of
a product is not simply the product of
the derivatives it's what it's this more
complicated thing here now by the way
remember I said to you I'm not a huge
fan of this - notation right if I would
should write this without dashes it
would look like this V do you on DX
that's what you - really needs + u dv/dx
that's what it really means but as you
can see and as I alluded to before right
this is something you want to pull out
like that you know what I have to
remember and this just kind this is very
easy to remember right and that's
powerful right like this is more
descriptive but this is easier to access
right and so sometimes you got to go for
that yes
that's not the face I remember writing
this on a paper that feedback and
someone said well let's take me